c'est dans le hameau de romainville à
magny les hameaux que jonas et mélanie
de la lande ont construit sur leurs
terres un labyrinthe de maïs une
structure ouverte depuis le 1er août
pour mettre leurs fermes en valeur afin
de d'apporter une diversification sur la
ferme de nous faire connaître et de
faire venir du public explique un petit
peu le milieu agricole
on a décidé de mettre en place un
labyrinthe de maïs donc pour faire une
activité pour les jeunes pendant l'été
est aussi bas pour faire connaître
expliqué la culture du maïs un
labyrinthe de plus de deux hectares qui
même par fortes chaleurs plaît beaucoup
aux enfants
c'était un vrai labyrinthe et il était
haut et on pouvait pas même en portant
on pouvait pas voir au dessus et comme
ça on pouvait pas triché un parcours
d'environ trois kilomètres qui a aussi
une vocation pédagogique grâce aux
panneaux explicatifs sur la récolte du
maïs présent dans le labyrinthe ya
combien de visiteurs ici par jour qui
viennent ans c'est assez variable en
fonction de la température c'est surtout
la météo qui fait venir plus ou moins
les personnes
on a démarré avec une cinquantaine de
personnes par jour et pendant la
canicule on a on a fermé c'était trop
trop trop chaud pour pouvoir circuler
du coup le public c'est quoi ces des
familles cédé plus des amis c'est comme
c'est quoi c'est surtout des familles
qui on a une activité en plein air on
n'a pas besoin d'être masqué on est à
peu près tranquille
donc ils viennent ils se retrouvent ici
passent une après-midi après il reste à
l'ombre sur les bancs à regarder les
animaux et à discuter à jouer sur la
pelouse ou en plus du labyrinthe
les deux agriculteurs sont en pleine
construction d'une boutique de produits
de la ferme
l'idée voilà c'est de mettre en avant
déjà les produits que nous
on assure l'exploitation donc on
transforme notre blé tendre en farine
semi complète qui écrasé sur une meule
de pierre le colza en huile de colza
on a aussi des lentilles vertes convient
juste de moissonner et du miel la
boutique ouvrira fin septembre le
labyrinthe quant à lui est ouvert en
août du mardi au dimanche et en
septembre les week-ends de 14 heures à
18h30